big news tonight out of t-mobile arena
some
fans will be allowed in for golden
knights games that's going to be fun the
arena
will allow 15 percent capacity just
another sign
of our positive road to recovery sports
director chris matthews live in studio
with when this will be happening chris
yeah remember unlv football was the
first to allow fans back and then nascar
and now the golden knights golden
knights will see as you mentioned brian
15 percent of t-mobile arena filled with
those fans that's about
a little below what the governor said
and he was allowing the
local state officials are setting their
own capacity numbers
below what governor sysolak is allowing
and that's not sitting well with the
owner of the vegas golden knights
the governor is allowing 20 percent plus
suites
of certain occupations occupancy in
suites
the local clark county health authority
has said 15 percent including everything
which
is silly the governor has the right
statistics he has the right information
why not let us put some some fans at
t-mobile
and support our players and let the fans
enjoy our team and enjoy the game again
all right as soon as we hear
when you can get the golden ticket for
those games beginning march first we'll
let you know